heather is in orlando
hi heather welcome to dave ramsey show
thank you um first off i want to say
y'all have been such a blessing in my
life um
i have i paid off a hundred eleven
thousand dollars worth of debt
i have a fully funded emergency fund and
i've been through entre leadership and
business boutique and uh
i really appreciate what you guys teach
wow thank you
that's amazing made a huge difference in
my life way to go i'm proud of you
i needed good guidance so that's where
you guys all came in
i feel like your family thank you we are
how can we help today
um my husband and i just had a little
boy he's three months old
he's awesome we i'm thrilled to be a mom
um i'm feeling a little overwhelmed
financially
thinking of all the different things to
provide for him
college and helping him get on the right
path
also we i just finished the emergency
fund
but
saving a down payment for a house
putting away money for retirement
putting away money for his college it
all kind of hits at once when you have a
little guy like i hear it all in theory
on your show but now it's for real
and um i'm just wondering some guidance
yeah
so how much you paid off a hundred and
how much debt
a hundred eleven thousand yeah when you
started that
debt snowball that was that tall
that felt unattainable didn't it
it sure did and then as you chipped away
at it
you started going i think i got this and
as the snowball got bigger and bigger
and bigger and you were reaching towards
the end of it you were like
oh now i see it i got it right
remember those emotions yep exact same
thing is going to happen here
exact same thing is going to happen here
you know finish your emergency fund
and you're going to start saving for
retirement or a house whichever you want
to do
if you want to do baby step 3b as you
know you've listened to the theory you
said
you can stop everything and save up a
down payment or you can while you're
doing your
15 or some portion towards retirement up
to 15
you start saving for the down payment on
your house but as you know
and you know the story heather you go
baby steps four five and six at the same
time
once you start doing them you start
doing a little bit towards junior
make sure you're putting your 15 away
and you as you guys make more and more
money you'll put more towards junior and
junior
is going to be just fine because he's
got a really smart mom
and heather i just want to encourage you
you're you're doing great and you're
okay like you are
this is so new and heather i remember
those feelings i remember someone
telling me when i was pregnant with my
first
son carter that when you have a child it
feels like your your heart is walking
around outside your body it feels so
vulnerable you feel like the weight of
the world on your shoulders this whole
new level of responsibility
that is unlike anything you've ever felt
before and that's that's a little bit of
what you're feeling
and and i just want to encourage you
you're doing
great and you are okay and part of it is
i'm just going to go on a limb here and
say part of this is the fact that
you're three months out like i remember
i remember one time when i was reading
to carter he was maybe two months old
and i'm reading this book and dave
seriously i just start
crying imagining him going to college
and he's like three months old you got a
lot of hormones heather you got a lot of
feelings
it's just it life is overwhelming right
now you're not getting any sleep
so i just want to say hey you're okay
you're okay you're doing a great job
and you're gonna continue to do a great
job and you're gonna take care of that
baby
you're doing awesome just like when you
started that snowball when he is six
you're gonna look back and go wow we got
this we have this retirement thing going
we got this
college thing going we almost got the
house paid off and we're
going to be in great shape and you're
going to feel exactly the same way as
accomplished as you feel right now about
debt you're going to feel that way
about his college fund and all these
other things you're worrying about
christy's right you got this
you're doing a good job